bello e tutti ragazzi poi venuto nessuno
video sono fa vj ma che cazzo succede
oggi siamo sugli under e simulator lei
under
ecco le candele sono quelle ragazze che
negli anime all'apparenza sono belle e
tranquille in realtà fanno qualsiasi
cosa del tipo ammazzare le persone o
sette giorni e poi crepo ragazzi ma qui
ma manco in the ring almeno sono una
bella gnocca
almeno quello buongiorno senpai shrine
certo questo lo spazzolino che ho rubato
a casa del san pio con il quale mi
pulisco i denti ogni volta è una
sensazione meravigliosa sito tipo di sci
con i denti con lo spazzolino usato di
un altro meraviglioso cerotto che ho
strappato al semplice un po del suo
delizioso sangue sopra o mio dio neanche
i tuoi light che cazzo va bene la sme
comunque sono esageratamente posso
cambiarmi le mutande è il mio gioco
preferito di sempre facile vedere almeno
le cose che si cambia andiamo a scuola
andiamo a scuola che andiamo uccidere un
po di persone mai così 7 del mattino
prima di entrare a scuola che bella che
sono carico
vai con la scopa vorrei parlare con lei
ascolta zia vuoi fare la pecorino volevo
semplicemente dirti che sei meravigliosa
oggi davvero o no grazie
se troppo gentile e poi ti uccido katana
prova a prenderla vedrà che sta
visibilmente almada aveva beda e succede
sentiti a ae le tette grosse che
potrebbe salvarti la vita è ferma ferma
esatto che bello qual è il tasto
d'attacco cos'è ma come qualcosa vuol
dire io posso cambiare i capelli con un
tasto si e fatto proprio bene cassano a
macomer da oh merda mi hanno visto mi
hanno visto devo ammazzarvi quali store
anzola ucciso luci anche te stronza
[ __ ] di merda eh vabbè non importa se
siete morti tanto non sa arrivate un
cazzo near balia devo posso trascinare i
corpi come e se passa qualche cristiano
non ha visto cazzo stavo semplicemente
camminando su questo corpo morto ma non
sono stato i ragazzi non sono stata io
non sono stato io allora stavamo
mangiando dei ketchup e lui è allergico
a caccia per questo c'è la maglietta
sporca non per quel 2 cazzo corri 1 sta
scappando via tutti gli sono lì da tutti
gli sono prendi il coltello veloce si no
[ __ ] vabbè vabbè vabbè mi uccido
uguale ma lui lui è scappato ma vabbe
madonna che strage ho fatto ma dove vai
dove vai mi ammazzano anche le famiglie
ha ucciso un po di gente
no è la polizia rivelata 4 minuti e 20
secondi devo trovare una scusa
plausibile discolparmi stavamo mangiando
erano tutti allergici a caccia tranne io
i sospetti le crimine conducevano agli
under e chan che è stata arrestata dalla
polizia ma no ma come van holt pro che
nessuno poteva sospettare avevo un piano
perfetto ma cazzo
e vabbè dai è stato divertente ma ci
riprova visibilmente armata ragazzi ho
solo una siringa altri semplicemente se
non a drogata c'è sempre
posso fare delle foto semplice posso
fare delle foto sempre 15 masturbo sopra
kai shek si ok prendo la siringa vado a
drogarmi già sempre c'è una [ __ ] che
sta a 6 metri dal mio semplice vistare
almeno 12 km e 426 metri perché se no va
bene lui da [ __ ] come ti permetti è
morta lo judo sempre non sono stata io
ma sono stata io no no no art project
ragazzi è finita sempre la mia ma più
perché mi ha visto uccidere una persona
va bene lei che sarà 4 centimetri dal
mio sempai lurida [ __ ] che l'udeur
uccide con tu mi stai sul culo tesoro ma
come stai il colpo sei bella mio dio ti
stanno benissimo che si capelli ti do
ano sei meravigliosa meraviglioso ti
giuro scontri devo andare però ci
vediamo è perché siamo amiche amiche del
cuore lurida [ __ ] di merda madonna
conto mi stai sul culo so per certo che
voi donne fatte così quando vi
incontrate sicuro ho sempre sospettato
questa cosa o mio dio come sa cos'è sta
roba
[Musica]
marcia [ __ ] o mio dio no no non ci
credo non ci voi non ci sto credendo no
ragazzi come ho fatto a non scoprire sta
roba prima se fai ti salvo io sono tutti
nei giganti non puoi salvarti se vai che
sono solo io come donna non può amarti
nessuno perché hanno tutti gli 825 di
piede è la cosa più bella e sexy e in
stile michael jackson che abbia mai
visto chic amaro con cui correre qualche
dette che c'hai chiodino mamme col
telefono come sempre se poi ti salvo io
se petto e poi semmai mi hanno dato
se fai mi sto guardando ragazzi se vai
sì lo so che stai guardando quelle belle
gambe di quella brutta [ __ ] la marzo
ragazzi l'ammazzo andiamo ad uccidere
nei po tutti i giganti che belli
la cosa che sto vedendo non ridi giganti
di merda volete barista mi sta uccidendo
tutti stanno incastrando tutte
nell'edificio e uccisi ok
fantasia così impari a guardare il mio
sempai colt azienda afferma e la roba
senza il gioco chi non sense io abbia
mai fatto nella mia vita da carla gas e
la mia prossima arma sarà un cacciavite
dovrà fare il killer con questo velo se
riesco a fare qualcosa dalla sentite ce
la posso fare
fuori non mi ha visto nessuno non è
visto nessuno trascina corpo veloce chi
mi ha visto chi cazzo
kimi avi luridi strozzino ferma ferma
bastardo fa è la madonna come caso come
ha fatto a colare il sangue di sotto
fermo devo arrivare a darvi prima di
loro cazzo non potete scoprirmi ucciso
anche lessi addio già fatta trascinare i
corpi via prima che mi scopro a [ __ ]
me lo nascondo miopia nascondo qua
dietra che non troveranno mai corpi ecco
qua perfetta e tanto non sembra che sia
nascosto qualcuno andrà a prendere la
topina che lo scoprano [ __ ] ho
dovuto ucciderti soltanto perché mi hai
scoperto perché se ti facevi i cazzi
tuoi non ti ucciderò la prossima volta
impara a farti il sito guarda non ti
metto nell'altra scalate ti metto una
scala e uno in un'alta perfetto perfetto
ragazzi ho finito il mio delitto posso
tornare a casa nessuno mi ha scoperto e
l'ultima ce la posso fare
ma anche un paio d'ore queste si stanno
incrociando ma non me ne frega niente la
devo uccidere [ __ ] decisa bisogna devo
trascinare senza che sempre mi vada via
oddio non sta succedendo
no staccati da ecco non devi farti
prendere dal fatto che si avvicinano
sempre trascina prima che ti veda non mi
ha visto non mi ha visto dall'alto ti
guardano non lo avrei mai non lo avrei
more che cosa sta succedendo fa prendeva
un mio dio denudata se io tipo vedo no
no no no noi come sembra ma non ci credo
non cogliamo togliermi non pensavo
rimanesse di fermo va dai ragazzi
concluso più perché sei stato
stranissimo cosa sta succedendo o mio
dio è la punizione per chi non soddisfa
il proprio amore in tostapane in faccia
è un gioco veramente uno dei giochi più
strani che abbia mai fatto ma ok è
quindi ragazzi lo so che ci sono delle
candele tra voi che mi guardano mentre
vado a dormire
non lo so ragazzi ma io sono molto più
gentile di sempre se poi non mi caga di
striscio ma io caldo le persone spero
che esca il gioco completo perché la
demo non si capisce un cazzo ma
fino ragazzi concludo qui a pisodio
spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto il
servizio è piaciuto maastricht ha
lasciato momento mi piace anche a facili
facebook e co veleni video tratta una
descrizione so se ci siete o mio dio a
un tostapane è un killer abbia capito la
gara ragazzi quando uno gliela vuole
dare non la prendono neanche